[Musique]
l'université s'était également jointe à
la grève une décision de la présidence
qui a eu peu d'effets sur le terrain les
étudiants ne paraissons guère mobilisé
nicole fâché patrick day us
le conseil d'administration de
l'université a voté cette journée de
mobilisation pour protester contre la
réforme de l'enseignement supérieur que
vient de proposer le gouvernement il
dénonce le manque de concertation lors
de son élaboration et les dangers
qu'elles présentent pour l'avenir des
universités
conséquence de cette journée des examens
ont été reportés une réunion
d'information est organisée cet après
midi animé par des membres du conseil
d'administration mais très peu
d'étudiants ayant participé
est-ce que vous avez été formé au moins
de la raison pour laquelle il avait
cette journée
cette grève en ce moment je pense que
peut-être que s'est attaché à ça du tout
je vois je vois pas mal d'affichage il
vous est sûrement filmer ça mais moi
j'ai rien vu je me sens pas du tout
concerné en tout cas je pense que c'est
important de manifester contre les
réformes et pas deux de repousser les
examens
cette action l'université souhaite
obtenir du gouvernement qu'il modifie
sans calendrier le projet de réforme des
universités doit normalement être votée
en juillet
[Musique]